hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's uh video on
overflow today is September 20th 2022.
I'll be talking about uh the e-minis
today e-minis have been under pressure
tomorrow we got fomc uh so we'll see
what's going to uh come to fruition this
week as far as uh the rates and what
effects going to have on the market but
you know when you trade order flow it
doesn't really matter the fundamentals
because you know people that trade order
flow are intraday Traders they're just
trading on a very short-term Horizon
we're not taking macro views of the
market like oh how's rates going to
affect the market you know for the next
couple of days or weeks or months even
no we're just more interested in the
flow that's coming into the market right
now and how we can trade it and you know
yesterday I made my video about the
point of controls in the bars you know
and the relationship to price and today
I'm going to talk about the opposite you
know yesterday was uh seemed like the
market kept going up today the Market's
Been Under Pressure all day and you know
we've been selling off and making new
lows so it's a good time to sort of talk
about the opposite of what I was talking
about yesterday in terms of
the market rallying off of lows and how
pointed controls can help you give you a
clue on areas that are going to be good
buying opportunities you know anytime a
market is at a low you want to have a
reason to be buying and if there's a
valid reason then yeah you take the
trade I mean it's not just go out there
and buy the dip you keep buying the dip
Market keep selling off and you're
standing there holding your
thing in your hand so to speak so let's
take a look at uh at this Market this is
e-minis it's just a simple one minute
chart
and we're watching you know as the
market makes a little so you know Market
opened up 8 30 and we started selling
off immediately and we're seeing you
know these nice big red bars down point
of controls
coming in towards the bottom but we're
closing uh below the point of controls
again which is nice and bearish this is
what you're expecting to see on a market
that's moving down here we're sort of
closing right on the level uh we're
making these lows here at 843 844 8 45
and you know Point control is all lined
up at the same level so you know we're
forming some balance in the market we
are closing you know this one would
close right on the point of control
um this one we closed well below it then
obviously got that green bar up point of
control still in the middle so we got
you know an area of balance in here at
what is that 69 and a half okay I mean
nothing to get too excited about one way
or the other right now
um
let's see if the market rallies it
doesn't right I mean it doesn't it did
go up to what is that 77 and a half and
started coming down you know my view is
still bearish on the market I mean
obviously we're trading down at the lows
there isn't really a major reason to be
buying in here you know we're coming
down into this low just looking at the
Deltas you know it's minus 600 minus 500
plus 372 minus 92 okay A plus a thousand
the point of controls are all lined up
and when you see pointed controls being
lined up like that you know it's telling
you the Market's balancing
you want to find another reason to be
getting long is there a lot of
aggressive buying well you got you know
the positive Delta but you're not seeing
imbalances per se in the market you have
one down here 105 against 22. but you
know what on a green candle that's the
most likely area we're going to have a
buying imbalance right off the low right
so you see one here one here
um that's just the most likely area in a
bar that you're going to have a buying
and balance on a green candle
Market does shoot up again you know it
shoots up about Five Points six points
and then starts coming down as we're
coming down into the lows okay worst
point of controls relative to price in
these bars well price is closing below
the point of controls okay we pop back
up a little bit again you know anytime
we hit a low there's always going to
attract some buyers coming in I thought
this Market could put in a nice little
rally here you know we're seeing this
Market come down the Delta is minus 700
minus 600 just 54 then plus 366 plus 930
plus a thousand
okay I thought this bar could be the
beginning of you know a move back up at
least you know probably 10 15 points it
only went you know basically from about
71 up to 75 not much of a rally then
just went sideways on you okay when a
market starts going sideways on you
watch what's happening with point of
controls relative to previous bars watch
what's happening with component controls
relative to price okay so we closed
below the point of control on this bar
then we go inside we go inside again so
you got two inside bars here
what's Point control is doing this bar
the point of control is lower than the
previous bar this green candle when a
control is lower even though we did
close up which you know is something you
like to see right you like to see the
bar close above the point of control I
don't like that the point of controls
over these three bars are going lower
though but price did reverse here so you
got to watch what's happening in the
next bar Can this bar break out of this
Bar's high at 75 and a quarter no it
can't it started to when two ticks
higher
and then just reverse it just collapsed
and close below the point of control so
now you got one two three four lower
point of controls
next bar Lower next part lower okay
Trend in point of controls is down right
price looks like it's sort of going
sideways in here right these four bars
prices going sideways more or less but
volume is migrating lower that's a
bearish sign right Mark comes down makes
a new low right yeah I was right it made
a new low you know but it made a new low
by what a point okay then it did bounce
back up a little bit did finally take
off that high and then sort of the same
thing started coming in again
want to control at this swing High goes
below it we're going to control
close sort of on it but we're still
below it you know it's a green candle it
did sort of make a run back up but it
still closed just on that point of
control then obviously this bar Lower
point of control
than the previous bar obviously closed
below same thing here lower point of
control
close below it right Market comes back
down makes a new low again great
then put a controls coming in at these
two new lows here put a control coming
in at the bottom point and wall and
price closing right on it okay again
it's kind of bearish potentially you can
make new low now here we got a ratio and
Divergence which is a bullish order flow
signal you've got a stack buying and
balance you got a market sweep taken off
in here nice positive Delta you know
which is a bullish sign so even though
you know we had the bearish signs in
here with the opponent controls in price
now we got this bar which is a lot got a
lot of bullish things going for it right
we're closing above the point of control
we do have a nice stacked imbalance
that's five levels deep we got
exhaustion print we got a Divergence we
got a ratio
that's very bullish right and the market
when I say rallied but again you know
from basically 60 you know 67 up into
the 70s sort of came back pulled back
down into the Stacked buying imbalance
right which is what you want to watch is
if you're going to pull back in there
you want to see that aggressive buying
from earlier hold more or less you want
this is going to be your support area
and it did hold and it went back up
again made another run up to 75 this
time and then it's just started
collapsing again okay closing below the
point of controls
in this bar this bar closed on it
obviously this particles below this bar
close below
this bar closed a little bit above it
and lower Point controls more or less on
this move down into this new low this
new low here okay
this one
what do you see right point of control
on this bar 937 we close at the low of
the bar
so we close in below the point of
control then this bar come down make a
new low right make a new low Drop from
62 and a half down to 59. point of
control coming in at 60 and a quarter
price
actually closed up here at 62 and a half
so well off our point of control to the
upside even though it's a red candle I'm
sorry closed at the 62 and a quarter not
a half
um
so it's well above even though it's a
red candle you know people say well it's
a pin bar okay yeah
um then obviously point of control
higher here
close above it Point control higher
close above it so you already got three
point controls
honestly or two going higher than this
one obviously this is your third one but
things are starting to look bullish and
what was important here is also
happening in the Delta similar to what I
was pointing out earlier you're coming
into new lows coming in hot minus a
thousand Delta minus 700 Delta minus
285. look at this Max Delta 0 0. so you
know it's strong you know it's just it's
almost like it felt like capitulation
taking place in the market everyone's
just like get out of the market I don't
care what prices and get me out of that
market strong selling very heavy volume
here coming in at the low 10 000 right
it's almost double the previous bar
which is 4 5 900 which is strong
previous bars three nine four eight okay
but the heaviest volume coming here
where It reversed look at the Min Deltas
relative to the final Delta on this red
candle
final Delta minus 1 10 1034
Min Delta the strongest
Delta was in the negative side in this
bar minus 1095. so it's about what is
that 60 contracts
off of that so it's closing basically
right near its Min Delta number it's at
zero Max Delta
cut the bar on the low minus 1200 it's
your strongest
Min Delta over any of these bars here
obviously
I mean obviously the volume is more
Max Delta zero again so you get two bars
with zero Max Delta
Min Delta went from minus 1200 final
Delta minus 700 so there was a shift of
about 500 contracts between the Min
Delta and the final Delta and even
though you see that well you see well
Mike the the Delta is negative
that's bearish right well yeah it it's
it's negative Delta for one
but what is happening with the Delta it
went from minus 1200 to only minus 700
so it gained 500 of it back
okay which is something important to to
watch for in the markets okay that sort
of those Delta flips then obviously this
next bar minus 285 okay so there was
some support of mine in here you got the
green candle small green candle
but negative Delta so it went from minus
1000 minus 700 minus 285
0 Max Delta zero Max Delta 53
Max Delta so there's some buying you
know took over in this bar when you see
zero Max Delta that doesn't mean there
was no aggressive mine in the bar it's
just telling you that
at no point in that bar was it positive
Delta
okay it's because the bar was under
heavy selling pressure again
zero Max Delta doesn't mean there was no
aggressive buying it just means that at
no point in that bar was the aggressive
buying
overwhelming the aggressive selling to
turn it positive in this bar did a
little bit plus 53 okay
but still ended up with negative Delta
now here you've got positive Delta of
all right Min Delta is only -33 Max
Deltas Plus 511.
so now you're starting to see that shift
right from what was very heavy
aggressive selling
in the Mac sorry in the Min Deltas with
very little Max Delta now you're seeing
very little Min deltas
and heavy Max deltas and we're closing
up near our Max Delta numbers 428 versus
511 714 versus 28 728 the Min Delta here
was only minus 23. okay so now you got
this nice rally off this low here you
know and it's coming in right this is a
Delta surge right here 428 714 957 but
again what I really love about this
this low is as it was coming into the
new low you got heavy selling going into
the low
but it's getting a little bit weaker
getting a little bit weaker and it's
meeting some supportive buying than the
aggressive buying more aggressive buying
even more aggressive buying
but you don't need to wait till this bar
closes I mean you can see the signs just
coming in here right by looking at the
max Delta in men that belt the max Delta
in Min Delta relationships and the
relationship to the final Delta and
what's happening again with the point of
controls where price is closing relative
to the point of controls and point of
control is going higher so really
the place to be getting long is
somewhere in this bar you know 64 to 66.
again even if you're late getting into
this bar 68 okay just sort of went
sideways before it popped higher you
know another 10 points
all right I mean I'm not gonna say you
want to bought it in here and sold it
way up here at the top no I mean you
would have bought it in here get that
pop up here going sideways this is where
you'd be getting out buying it at 68 in
here
ideally getting out in the 70s in the
mid 70s
and you know what else was interesting
today sort of coming into what time is
it here
there was
some decent volumes going through uh but
I'm not going to talk about that now
just sort of coming into these new lows
down here okay this is
right about where we are right now it's
just around I don't know what time is
this 145 or something like that
so we're coming on into these lows here
right this was the fresh low here that
we made at one o'clock 38 43 and a
quarter okay point of control right near
the bottom this is a Prominent Point of
control it's not highlighted you got a
Divergence
and a ratio in the next bar again which
is also bullish
but look as we're coming down where's
pointy controls okay and where's price
closing so point of control on this bar
for the controls coming in at 46 and a
half we close that obviously 46. here
point of control is coming in at 45 and
three colors close a little bit higher
okay at 46 and a half and then again
another red bar down point of control
coming in at five and a half we close
that uh five again point of control
coming at five this time we're closing
at four
okay now point of control coming at
three and a half but we reversed
but all of a sudden we're trading five
and a half so we're trading well above
our opponent control okay now you got a
Divergence you got the positive Delta on
the low of the day
almost a ratio 27.
I think I'm using 30. here's uh but
here's your bullish ratio right the 0.17
so I got this Vine imbalance sorry the
selling imbalance here the 302 so it's
telling me there's some support in this
market but again look at what's
happening in the Deltas you got minus
987 then one which is basically nothing
might as well it could have been zero
just one contract difference
then minus 435 minus 125 so you're
coming down into new lows and these are
new lows of the day at one o'clock
strong selling
weaker
weaker minus 987 minus 435 minus 125.
you know if
this minus 1 it's still negative but
again it's it's kind of neutral in that
sense right you know people are going to
say well you only got minus one so you
had some buying no Delta
when you have a smallish Delta you know
for me I have what I call
Delta new Troy uh confuses people
because people start thinking of options
especially when you you
talk you say the word Delta but if
like in the e-minis okay if there's a
Delta number that's plus or minus a 25
right so if it was -10 I would still
treat it the same I'd basically treat it
as as zero having no Effect one way or
the other that's because you know it's a
time-based chart the bar it chart just
closes because time is up
all right so even though it's minus one
you know if this was positive five I
would treat it the same as basically
having no real effect on my analysis so
Delta's getting weaker getting weaker
getting weaker also now it's getting
stronger plus 221 plus 377 plus 1251
again another surge but what you have
here is the Delta weakening then the
positive Delta coming in so the place to
be looking to buy it is potentially in
here in this bar you don't have to wait
till you see this big strong plus 1251
because by time you get triggered
getting into this trade you know you get
in at 50 51 52 when you could have been
looking at you know 48 49 a little bit
earlier and you know markets start going
up got up to 55 but then just sort of
went sideways before it finally popped
up here into the 60s Okay so
so hopefully you can see now how you're
able to put all these things together
point of control Delta the final Delta
the max Delta the Min Delta where price
is closing relative to the points of
control
so I'll end it there for now
um you know I have a
great rest of the week you know we got
fomc be careful if you're trading in the
markets uh tomorrow or the next day
everyone's expecting the FED to do
something who knows maybe they do it a
little bit sooner than everyone's
expecting to do it maybe they just come
out you know just right off the bat
we're doing three quarters of a point
we're doing a point you know that's what
used to happen back in the in the 90s
and everyone was expecting something to
happen and obviously the FED had to do
something so they just come out and did
it you know they don't need to go
through a long press conference oh this
and that just get it get it over with
so be sure to like the channel subscribe
if you haven't already you know I'm
trying to post a video up every day
whenever possible if the markets are
open and again I appreciate you taking
the time to watch these videos thanks
everyone bye-bye